[Música]
[Aplausos]
me llamo facundo bogarín
soy ciego
pobre no
bueno esperen que falta me llamo facundo
bogarín mi mamá es ciega
mi papá de ciego mi hermano ciego y
hasta el perro era ciego en serio ahora
sí pobre
bueno en realidad no sé si pobre es la
vida y la familia como la conocí si bien
yo no nací ciego si me crié en un ámbito
de mucha ceguera por así decirlo ya sea
en mis padres bueno en la familia o en
amigos de la familia desde chico fue
natural para mí que haya gente que no
vea nunca me llamó la atención lo que sí
me llamaba la atención eran algunas
miradas
en la calle yo por ahí va caminando con
mis padres y me cruzaba gente que se
quedaba mirando con una mirada pesada
una mirada de lástima no una mirada de
pobre ciego
gente que no tenía ni idea de cómo eran
mis padres de los geniales que eran mis
padres pero que hacen todo
se quedaban con esa mirada que no los
culpo seguramente estaba estaban
influidos por el estereotipo social que
hay del ciego
generalmente alimentado por las novelas
cuando en una novela se mostró a un
ciego normal siempre se lo muestra por
él y sentado triste lamentándose
pobre ciego y bueno desde chico tuve que
aceptar que mis padres por ahí nunca
iban a tener un auto o que nunca íbamos
a poder quedarnos dibujando toda una
tarde de lluvia o que nunca íbamos a
mirarnos profundo a los ojos y decirnos
te quiero
sí pero también crecí en un hogar en un
hogar lleno de amor de respeto de apoyo
de diversión cosas esenciales e
invisibles a los ojos
por ahí fue mi infancia feliz era un
chico que le gustaba mucho nadar le
gustaba mucho dibujar y andar en skate
en patineta
el tema fue que allá por mis 15 años más
o menos
me quedo ciego
si la ceguera había dejado de ser una
cuestión de mi familia y del entorno y
pasaba a ser algo en mí también
y la verdad que me costó si todo se
complica en la adolescencia imagínense
encima a quedarse ciego fue difícil me
enoje menos que con el destino menos que
con mis padres me enoje conmigo me enoje
con el mundo
porque todo aquello que me gustaba hacer
se me dificultaba
tenía que aprender a manejar mi vida de
una forma distinta tenía que aprender a
manejar me yo en la calle porque cambia
manejarte en la calle viendo o sin ver
entonces para ir al club a nadar tenía
que aprender a manejarme en la calle
pasaba mucho tiempo encerrado en mi casa
y bueno claramente todo el tiempo que
estaba en casa no podía dibujar obvio y
andar en skate menos
entonces comencé a escuchar música amigo
me refugié en el rock empecé a tocar una
guitarra que había tirada en el placard
y con el tiempo
empecé a soñar
yo soñaba tener una banda una banda de
rock con mis amigos y soñaba vivir de
gira
yo quería vivir de gira por todos lados
pero bueno estaba todo el tiempo en casa
y casi que no tenía amigos así que bueno
tuve que aceptar mi ceguera y salir a la
calle salir a la vida sin salir me lleno
me lleno de buenos amigos conocí muy
buena gente empecé a juntarme con un
grupo un grupo de pseudo punk del barrio
éramos un grupo de chicos de muy mal
aspecto pero de muy buenas intenciones
no éramos cool para nada cool éramos
bastante sucios desprolijos pero éramos
jóvenes y auténticos y eso estaba más
que bien yo me llamo facundo ya les dije
era un nombre bastante común se ve a
fines de los 80 en los 90 en mi
generación hay un montón de facundo en
el grupo éramos 5 facundo entonces hubo
que empezar a diferenciarlos a cada uno
porque se llamó de bueno facu pueden que
facu
el cielo
y bueno termine siendo el ciego es mi
apodo
hoy en día yo soy fan del cielo
el ciego
y porque la gente me pregunta pero no te
molesta que te digan ciegos que se
refieren a vos como el ciego
y no
no la verdad que no sé por qué tendría
que molestarme molesto por ahí es que te
digan no videntes impide
cieguito nada
diminutivos que son innecesarios para
las palabras ridículas invidentes
es mucho más fácil que sea ciego aparte
bueno mis padres son ciegos
yo soy ciego yo soy el ciego de los
pides aparte también convengamos que
nuestros apodos no eran tan difíciles
están pensados al que tenía la cresta
más larga le decíamos el punky a uno que
había venido de uruguay y le decíamos
bueno el uruguayo a uno
a uno que hablaba finito y tenía la voz
finita le decíamos agudo
les seguimos diciendo a uno
y bueno ya que andaba conmigo para todos
lados en esa época del que más andaba
con el ciego le quedo lazarillo
no no lo aplaudan no no lo conocen
gracias
bueno básicamente no me molesta es un
apodo y un apodo tiende a hacer algo
bien descriptivo de la persona está bien
que así sea por ahí fue también mi
adolescencia aceptando la ceguera
conociendo gente nueva aceptando a la
gente distinta y la gente aceptando me
aceptando nos todos tuve varias bandas
por suerte como quería
voy a contar los nombres porque son muy
buenos una banda se llamaba descarte
otra banda se llama bruta decepción
y otra banda se llamó the strong mcclure
gran nombre para mí no importa sigo con
esto fue un paréntesis
la cuestión es que haya más o menos por
mis 20 años me entero que el centro
argentino de teatro ciego estaba
haciendo un casting que buscaba actores
ciegos dos cosas por un lado me entero
que hay un teatro ciego que no sabía
bien de qué se trataba pero sabía que
existía ahora y también me entero
descubro que pueden haber actores ciegos
y bueno si bien yo no era actor de hecho
nunca había pensado en actuar si eras yo
era el ciego
y tenía que ir fui y de hecho quede e
inmediatamente empecé a trabajar por
suerte me gane la confianza de mis
directores de mis compañeros hice muchos
amigos y descubrí el teatro el
maravilloso oficio del actor para los
que no saben lo que es teatro ciego el
centro argentino de teatro ciego es el
único teatro a nivel mundial que
desarrolla todos sus espectáculos en
completa oscuridad esto se trata de
bloquear por completo el sentido de la
vista en el espectador y mediante del
estímulo del resto de los sentidos ya
sea el oído el olfato el tacto
generar estímulos para que alguien pueda
comprender una obra de teatro la pueda
transitar y disfrutar sin la necesidad
de verla algo completamente innovador el
teatro si no tiene dos partes
interesantes
por un lado está la cuestión social de
inclusión laboral que permite la
inclusión de actores ciegos en el ámbito
teatral y también la inclusión de
actores normó visuales o actores que ven
al ámbito de la oscuridad la inclusión
se da de ambas partes y por otro lado
también está la cuestión artística el
teatro ciego es un grupo teatral que
está cambiando a nivel mundial la forma
de hacer teatro con una apuesta
completamente innovadora y
revolucionaria la gente muchas veces
sale de las obras sorprendidas alteradas
emocionadas contentas eufóricas y te
dicen guau me encantó estuvo buenísimo
pero
as o no vidente
uy no pobre
bueno ya dije no se dice no vidente en
principio se dice ciego y segundo si soy
pobre es porque no vendimos muchas
entradas por diez anoche pero el resto
no yo les recomiendo que se lleven la
experiencia que vivieron que se lleven
su alegría y viva hasta que el resto
está todo bien
para ir redondeando un poco esto que
hasta ahora aparece un resumen de mi
vida lo que bueno que es un resumen de
mi vida
hoy en día trabajo en el elenco de giras
de teatro ciego soy el director del
elenco de giras de teatro ciegos que
como su nombre lo dice es un grupo
itinerante que va por todos lados
haciendo funciones ya recorrimos casi
toda argentina fuimos a uruguay paraguay
chile méxico españa etcétera o sea
qué se podría decir
que hoy vivo de gira con mis amigos
qué bien no el ciego que cumplió su
sueño
pobre y seguimos en la misma
bueno en realidad tampoco estoy acá para
hablar de cómo cumplir un sueño si los
sueños se cumplen o si son metas o que
son no ese es el punto no estoy acá para
debatir si soy pobre por el hecho de no
ver porque también eso estaría diciendo
que alguien que ve sólo por el hecho de
ver es rico no es un debate mucho más
profundo que no lo vine a dar estoy acá
para hablar de la inclusión
[Música]
sigue esta palabra que tanto se viene
usando últimamente por suerte tanto se
viene usando y creo que para empezar a
hablar de la inclusión
hay que diferenciar algunos tipos de
inclusiones por un lado está la
inclusión social
que depende en primer en primera
instancia de el estado si de estado que
tiene que asegurar el acceso a la
educación a la salud al trabajo a la
igualdad de oportunidades para todos
también hay muchas ong y organizaciones
que aportan su grano de arena
a la inclusión está la inclusión social
por otro lado que es donde quiero hacer
hincapié está la inclusión humana que es
lo que pasa entre nosotros individuos ya
dentro de la sociedad
inclusión que para mí se tiene que dar a
través de la aceptación la aceptación
como un motor para relacionarnos con los
demás
aceptando nos como somos nosotros ni
mejores ni peores distintos ni buenos ni
malos distintos y también aceptando al
otro como es distinto todos somos
distintos
pero la inclusión humana muchas veces se
termina dando a través de la lástima si
a través de incluyamos al pobre ciego al
pobre alto al pobre gordo y la lástima
la lastima nos lleva a ningún lado
porque si uno ejerce la lástima si uno
mira al otro con lástima automáticamente
se está poniendo en un escalón superior
y mirando al otro desde arriba pero es
lo que uno cree porque uno no sabe cómo
se siente el otro o cómo se cree el otro
o qué es lo que puede hacer el otro
esta inclusión también se viene dando
mucho yo la la tránsito cotidianamente
de pobres y de joven y que te incluimos
y no está tan bueno me parece hay que
hacer hincapié en la aceptación en la
otra e inclusión
habría que dejar de poner la lupa por
ahí sobre la discapacidad y ponerla
sobre la capacidad porque supongo que
nadie es perfecto que todos tienen algo
que le cuesta y también todos tienen
algo que les es fácil que le sale bien
que les gusta que los emociona que los
alegra bueno entonces poner la lupa
sobre eso
por ejemplo cuando a mí se me encomienda
dirigir el elenco de giras de teatro
ciego también se me pide que forme un
elenco nuevo de actores para trabajar en
la oscuridad
como ya dije trabajan actores que ven y
actores que no ven
en una charla con el director general de
teatro ciego con martín bondone estaba
hablando y le digo bueno mira en el
lincoln nuevo hay un actor que tiene
como 30 años de teatro tiene casi la
misma cantidad de tiempo que yo de vida
el de teatro
desde donde paro a dirigir a una persona
así
que como hago yo para ganarme su
confianza para dirigirlo para indicarle
cosas y ahí martín me dice bueno él
puede tener mucha experiencia de teatro
mucha carrera muchos años
pero la oscuridad es tuya no la
experiencia en la oscuridad la tenés vos
entonces anda desde ahí párate y dirigía
ese elenco
por suerte estuvo todo bien el elenco se
formó genial y estuvo todo bien
la cuestión es que esto es un ejemplo de
cómo revertir la discapacidad
y convertirla en una capacidad
es interesante esto hay que aceptar que
todos somos distintos pero que todos por
así decirlo servimos para algo
si después de esto alguien quiere seguir
pensando en tus pobres y uruguay mirada
a la verdad está todo bien a mí déjenme
así con mi familia con mis amigos con mi
ceguera porque está todo bien pero si
piensa en que la única forma que todos
seamos iguales es aceptar que todos
somos distintos
sí
y para que lo piensen los voy a dejar
por un instante nomás a ciegas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]